no dry land in sight
Waters have breached the banks of the
Chari River
outside Chad's Capital
we didn't know what we should do we are
now suffering as you can see the
government has to make a decision to
help us we are now doing men's work
because our husbands have passed away
and every one person has six or seven
children to take care of
18 of the country's 23 provinces are
impacted the president has declared a
national emergency
This Disaster is from climate change it
is one of the most severe the region has
seen in years it's making it hard for
people to keep their heads above water
on the other side of the river in
Cameroon a small Market town has also
been submerged
the water entered our house I saved my
children but then the house collapsed
now my things are in the water and we
can't recover anything
rains cause flooding in this region
every year but it has never been this
bad since Sunday thousands of people are
estimated to have been made homeless
since last year the rain has handicapped
me and I've lost two children but thank
God I recovered and I am on my feet now
but this year it happens again and again
and now I'm a refugee so help
with roads underwater canoes are now the
only way to get around
and the river keeps Rising
Leah Harding Al Jazeera